PRITHPAL BHOGLI:
We're going to be
talking about API monitoring for
connected customer experiences.
So I'll be the co-host
today, Prithpal Bhogil.
I'm part of the
Apigee product team.
It's nothing but a
pleasure to have you folks
attend a session this morning.
Been with the Apigee team
for a little over five years.
And I drive two different
areas for the product team,
including API monitoring.
And I'm super excited to
have Luke join us here,
from Urban Science.
And he is my partner in
crime for today's session.
And he will also walk us
through the Urban Science story
and how they're
leveraging benefits
from the API
monitoring capability
that we're just
about to talk about.
OK.
Excellent.
With that, some
basic housekeeping.
So this year, at Next, we have
the ability for the attendees
to be able to ask questions
on the Dory Q&A link.
You should be able to find
that in your Google Next app.
So please feel free to ask
any questions out there.
We also have two microphones
up here, as well.
And we'll save sometime
towards the end for some Q&A
live, and both Dory, as well.
OK, so just a brief
recap of the agenda.
We'll talk a little bit
about why API monitoring has
become so critical.
We'll talk about some
of the common solutions
which are available
in the market today
and how the integrated API
monitoring is different.
And then we'll actually hear
live from Luke about Urban
Science's story and how
they've achieved the benefits
from that solution.
So if I was to do a
quick vote out here,
how many out here
in the audience
think they've used at
least one API today
on the way to this conference?
It's got to be everyone--
Uber, ordered something?
OK.
So API are becoming
mainstream, right?
To me, there is no
more powerful fact
than saying it's entered
our each and everyday life.
On a daily basis, you're
probably hitting more than five
or 10 APIs, at a minimum.
In this world, when
people are talking
about data transformation,
enterprises
are morphing them,
themselves, into entities
where their products
are nothing but APIs.
So if you transact your
capabilities as APIs
with your employees,
with their partners,
APIs become extremely
critical in how you are
perceived in the marketplace.
For us, personally, we pride
in powering successful API
programs for many of
our key customers.
And I'm really happy
to talk about that.
We have nearly doubled
our API traffic
since March of last year.
This is the amount
of API traffic
that we serve, just alone,
from our cloud platform.
So let's talk a
little bit about--
because the APIs have
become so front and center
of an enterprises' face out
there in this world, what
that means is,
operationally, the teams
have to be on top of ensuring
that APIs are performing
the way they should.
So no longer is it OK
for you to find out,
after the fact, that
hey, my API was down,
because it has downstream
effect of affecting many
of your partners who
may be banking on an API
to deliver connected
experiences of their own.
So ops teams need to be able
to monitor APIs in real time.
And, more importantly,
have the ability
to identify issues before
the consumers of the API
realize that there are
some issues out there.
That's a very important aspect.
And as you start to look
to some of these features,
you also want to be
able to quickly diagnose
where the issues are
so that you can lower
the mean time to resolution.
Now we do have many customers.
And when I talk to them,
they use several tools
out there today to be
able to get a sense of,
is something broken?
And what we find out,
in talking to them,
that synthetic monitoring
tools just aren't enough.
And what I mean by that is
these are typical API monitoring
tools which are sitting
outside the platform,
using some probes, to be able
to gather some key metrics--
such as suddenly there is a high
amount of error rate in an API,
or your latency just went up.
So they can tell
you what's broken--
of course, that's
the whole purpose.
But the key point
is, they are not
correlated with some
of the other things
that you need to be able to
perform useful forensics,
such as, can I go take
a look at the log file
right now at this moment to
understand, can I correlate
that, with a specific error?
So these tools tell
you what's broken,
but they don't really
give you the insight
into where it's broken
so you can quickly
fix what you need to.
So Apigee's API monitoring is
an integrated API monitoring
solution-- what we also call
a white box API monitoring
solution.
And so one of the
key advantages of it
being integrated
into the platform
is the ability for it to be able
to give you contextual insights
into your API issues.
So let's have an example.
If we have an error--
a higher error rate in
an API, suddenly-- you're
able to, through a
dashboard, visualize what
the error is, and then do
contextual drill downs to find
out the source of the error, and
also do some determinism on how
widespread the error is.
And, actually, I will be showing
that to you in a quick demo.
But the fact of
having API monitoring
integrated in the
platform not only
gives us the contextual
insight that we can
deliver to you, our customers.
But more importantly,
it opens up
some very interesting
possibilities,
which are just not possible
through a synthetic monitoring
solution.
Such as, imagine
a scenario where
you are the operational
team, and you're
using the Apigee Edge
platform, as an example,
to serve the APIs
to your consumers.
And let's say, for those
out here-- just a quick show
of hands.
How many users in the audience
have used Apigee Edge before?
OK, quite a few.
So Apigee Edge is a full
lifecycle API management
platform.
And you can use out-of-the-box
policies to do things like
traffic management.
Let's imagine a
scenario when you've
used one of the [? Spiker S ?]
policies to limit the amount
of traffic to one or more APIs.
And you have set
it to a threshold,
let's say, 1,000 per minute.
And maybe that sells--
you know, OK for your needs.
And suddenly there's
a catastrophic failure
in your back-ends, the
back-ends which are
backed into the API proxies.
And you want to be
able to, very quickly,
shut off traffic to them.
Well, one choice is
you can go and update
all the [? Spiker S ?]
policies one
by one, depending on the
number of API proxies.
But by that time, your back-ends
may not be able to survive.
So how about, if
we're able to lever
the power of the platform--
and this is something
we are working on.
And we give you
operator controls
to be able to dial down
the traffic to all the APIs
at once.
That is what we mean by
the [? close-to ?] aspect
of the integrated
API monitoring.
That is very powerful.
And that is something which
a synthetic monitoring
tool can never provide to you.
So Apigee API monitoring,
as I mentioned,
is integrated into the
platform, leverages
the best of Google tech.
We have some icons out here.
Just a quick sampling
of the underlying tech
that we use to power
these capabilities
and deliver it to our customers.
Precision diagnostics--
I'll just spent
a very few seconds on this.
This is a very important piece
of lowering your mean time
for diagnostics.
And this ties into
what I just mentioned.
Of course, tools can
tell you what's broken,
but we tell you
where it's broken.
I'll show that to
you in a few minutes.
Contextual insights--
this is essentially
where, once an issue or
an error is detected,
how do you really
take that, drill down
through different aspects, and
get the right level of insight,
which becomes very important for
you to resolve that issue once
and forever.
With that, let me just
quickly get into a demo.
If we can switch.
Awesome.
So this is my beautiful
Gmail background.
So you can see--
imagine in this case that I am
the ops person on a schedule,
and I've just recently
received an alert.
So, from my perspective, I
want to be able to go in.
And I can see that
there's a alert which
was filed for high latency.
And this alert tells
me what's going on.
You can see the
organization within Apigee
that's encountering the error.
It tells me that it
sustained latency
above what our threshold is.
And so I would like to go
and take a look at that.
Once I click on View Details--
and I'm hoping the demo
gods are with us today.
Looks like they are.
OK.
So this is the very
first entry point.
I got a alert.
And I came in.
And right away I
can see that there
are some issues with latency.
So this alert kind of
gives me some insight
into what's going on.
But more importantly, as
I start to scroll down,
these panels start to give
you some more, deeper insight.
So in this case,
as an example, I
can see that this
particular proxy--
the one which I
got alerted for--
has some high number of errors.
And I can click on
one of the cells
out here to go and figure
out what's going on.
So in this case, it
starts to give me
some insights into
the total latency
and where the error could be.
Now this alert is
extremely powerful for me
to take a peek on
what's going on.
But I would like to
go and investigate
this thing a little bit more.
So if I click on
the Investigate tab,
this starts to
give me what I mean
by the broad-spectrum
aspects of the platform.
So in this case, I
can see that there
are different
kinds of dimensions
that I can compare against.
We provide three
different panels here.
So I can compare Fault Code,
which could be something coming
right out of an API proxy.
Maybe you've written
up a new policy,
and that threw an error.
I see a very high number of
inverted access token errors
out here.
So as the operator,
I'm really curious.
I want to be able to
click on this time zone,
and then drill down.
What it tells me is that there
is a specific API proxy--
in this case, the one
that I got alerted on--
that is having this error.
But also, out here, if we have
developer applications which
are consuming it, you will start
to get a distribution by not
only the developer app,
but also by the target back
in the [? re-hitting. ?]
This is very powerful,
because not only can I
do this kind of analysis.
But more importantly, I
can go out here, and also
examine the logs.
And this is what I meant
by contextual insights
and drill down.
Typically, we see
customers doing this thing
from a combination of two
or three different tools.
You may get alerted of an issue.
You may then go and
determine that I
need to go find out and
[INAUDIBLE] the logs.
But in this case, you
have all that information
at your fingertips.
So in this case, I now start
getting some pretty detailed
information about where
the error is coming from,
which API proxy.
And I also, more
importantly, have
a Message ID that can be used to
correlate across other systems.
Right?
So this is just a
very simple example
of how you can use
these capabilities.
Additionally, we have also
integrated custom reporting
into this tool.
And so we talk to customers.
They examine this
very classical,
real-time to trending continuum.
And what that
means is, of course
they want to be
alerted in real time.
But they also want to
be able to then navigate
to perhaps a time frame
when the error actually
started occurring.
And this is a very common
scenario in use cases
where, let's say, you
deployed an API proxy.
OK?
And let's say your
latency threshold happens
to be 10 seconds, right?
But this API proxy,
deployed, starts
to creep up five
seconds, six seconds,
slowly over a period of time.
You just happen to notice
that the second week that it
crept over 10 seconds,
you got alerted.
But this continuum of
real time to trending now
gives you the ability to be able
to navigate that and see when
the error actually occurred.
You just got alerted of
this thing right now,
but that gives you
deeper insights
into when that happened.
So I'll just cover
a couple of screens
real quick out here this is
the Dashboard view, where
you can get some high-level
access into the total traffic,
the API which have the
top number of errors,
top latencies.
And then you can look into
different aspects out here.
Collections that are
[INAUDIBLE] of an APIs together.
What we have found is we
have several of our customers
who have operational teams
who owned those APIs.
They may be a central
operations team
who want to be the
dispatcher, if you would.
But then they monitor
groups of APIs
of certain characteristics.
You can do that easily
with Collections.
Another view I would like to
talk about is the Recent view.
In this case, this is
a very interesting view
where you can do what we
call is NOC-like analysis,
like a Network Operation Center.
So in this case,
this heat map view
gives you a peek into what's
going on, what's wrong.
And if I click on this
environment as an example,
double click on
this, it now starts
to give me a drill down
of different API proxies.
So I can come from the top
and see something as an error,
but then very quickly start
to drill on certain scenarios,
on certain API proxies, and then
being able to kind of examine
all the contextual information.
So think of this
as, if something
is wrong at a high level,
I can drill, drill, drill,
and go to the parts and
figure out what's broken.
The last part I want
to show out here
is the alerting capability.
The fact that I got an alert
from something out here
is something that you
can easily configure.
So here is an example of the
alert that we have configured,
that fired.
In this case, again, we
have some pretty interesting
heuristics.
You can go and do alerting
on different metrics--
in this case, latency.
But you can pick
status codes, for code
which may be emanating
from certain proxies.
And, more importantly, you can
see this pretty interesting
chart data out here.
It's called the Condition data.
So this gives you, as
the operator, the ability
to set the alert
at the right level
so that it's not too noisy.
So we aggregate
information, give you
what the latency is, and you
can see the chart and determine,
well, I really want I get
notified at this point in time.
OK?
So with this, I'm going to--
if you can switch back to
the presentation, please?
Awesome.
So with that, I would like to
invite Luke up to the stage,
here.
And Luke, please share
your story, thank you.
LUKE MERCIER: Excellent.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, Prithpal, for the
opportunity to speak today.
I'm going to take you through a
little bit about our experience
at Urban Science, and how we
got to where we're at today,
which is a really good spot.
We have over 650 APIs in
production running right now.
We're producing anywhere from
8 to 10 million transactions
a month, and growing
on a regular basis.
A little bit about me.
I've been with Urban Science
for about 10 years now.
I'm working inside
the customer space.
So all of our stuff is PII
related, really sensitive data
that we have to deal with.
Who we are at Urban Science--
we like data.
We're all about data.
We're all about big data.
And we use that data to
solve our client's mission
critical problems.
Our clients-- we're
in the Motor City--
they're pretty much all
automotive right now.
We're moving into retail
and health as we speak.
What we do is we
listen to our partners,
and they tell us what they need.
We help them solve their
mission critical problems,
and we do that with the data
and with the APIs that we have.
We're everywhere.
If you've bought a
car, looked at a car,
or thought about buying
a car, rode in a car,
you've probably
touched our software
and we've probably
touched your records
at some point or another.
A little map about where we are.
So what do we do?
So what we do at Urban Science
is we listen to our customers.
We solve our
customer's problems,
and we do it with data.
And we do it with loyalty.
And we do it repeatedly.
And we do it right,
every single time.
We do it to drive their profit.
We have a really unique
vantage point at Urban Science,
because we can see
the whole ecosystem.
We see the whole industry.
And we see it really
broadly and really deep,
across the whole thing.
We can optimize dealer networks.
And we use that optimization to
drive their marketing efforts
to their position
of their locations.
Again, pretty much anything
in the automotive space,
if you've bought a car
or looked at a car,
you've touched our software.
So what do we do?
I run the C4 Marketing
Intelligence Cloud.
That is a customer-centric
marketing intelligence
cloud to drive marketing
into the automotive space.
And we do it all with data.
Prithpal indicated
earlier that a lot
of customers and a
lot of businesses
are going to API products.
That's exactly what our
Marketing Intelligence
Cloud is.
It is just an API product.
We have no real front-end.
We have a bunch of APIs--
over 650 of them right now.
And we've integrated heavily
with Google in the Apigee
product to help us do that.
What we've done is we've
taken their products.
We've created the dev portal.
I'm going to take you
through the dev portal,
show you how we've of
structured that a little bit.
And then take you into our
API management platform
and show you where
my ops teams live
their lives, every single day.
I'm going to take you
into our real-life system
so you can see exactly
what's going on.
So we do all of
everything we do, and we
do it to empower our
marketing, to drive business
inside the automotive space,
and to increase our shopper
experience.
That happens,
again, in real time.
And so we have millions
of transactions
flying through this API
management platform that's
transacting with PII
data in some cases,
and a lot of really
highly sensitive data.
So security was really
important for us,
which is one of
the primary reasons
that we chose Apigee
in API management.
We didn't want to write
that security layer.
We needed authentication,
authorization, access,
and auditing.
And we needed that because of
the customer-centric approach
that we were taking.
So our API program--
basically, we had to figure
out why we wanted to do API.
So about 2016, we
started down the track
of digital
transformation, right?
You guys have heard
it all day, every day,
for the last couple of days.
We needed to build
a platform that
would be used industry-wide.
But we didn't want to
build the solutions, right?
We wanted to build
a platform that
would empower other companies,
other internal teams,
to build those solutions.
We had access to the data.
All that data, the breadth
and the width of data,
was very valuable,
but inaccessible.
So we needed to open it up.
We needed to open it up
and make it accessible.
We needed to expose that
data, both internally
to other development teams
at Urban Science, as well
as external partners.
Marketing agencies--
if you guys were
at some of the other
sessions with Viant.
We've done a lot of stuff to
empower marketing agencies
with some of this data as well.
But not only do we need
to make it exposed,
we needed to make it easy.
Terabytes and terabytes
of data moving around.
Automotive's a pretty
legacy industry.
Boy, they love their flat files.
But that didn't work.
You can't move the
data fast enough--
at a high enough velocity--
without exposing some
sort of API interface.
Our customers, they were
all internal and external--
both data providers
and data consumers.
And so not only did our API
platform have to expose data,
but it also had to
ingest and ingress
additional data from
other providers,
other teams within Urban
Science, and other teams
externally.
So we needed APIs
on the front end
to collect that data, and
then APIs on the back-end
to also egress it back out.
So why did we choose Apigee?
Back in '16-- that
was before they were
bought by Google, actually.
We partnered with
Apigee and then
two weeks later, we learned
that Google acquired them.
I heard that news, I'm
like, good decision.
But we needed and we required
proper, mature API management--
not, I think I understand APIs.
But really API management.
Somebody who
understood the needs
of the security, the needs of
the auditing and the analytics.
We needed something
that was easy--
easy to build, easy to maintain,
and easy for developers
to get access to.
We didn't want to
reinvent the wheel.
We didn't want to build
all of that infrastructure.
We wanted to focus on building
our microservices, our APIs,
and get them out to market.
And again, we didn't want to
create that security layer.
I know, I sound like
a broken record.
But that security layer
is super, super important
with the sensitivity
of the data.
So the C4 Marketing
Intelligence Cloud--
that is our API product today.
Fully integrated with Apigee.
Like I said, we
have over 650 APIs
published, doing anywhere from
8 to 11.5 million a month.
It ebbs and flows.
If you run an API program,
or monitor or watch one,
you hit those milestones, right?
In 2016, we hit our first
1,000 transaction day.
It's like wooh,
1,000 transactions!
And a few weeks later,
it was like 100,000.
And then it was like, 500,000.
And then it was like, a million.
And it was like, 5 million?
I'm like, oh man, 5 million.
We're going to need some
more infrastructure.
So I'm really happy to hear what
they announced earlier today.
It's going to great.
It's going to make
my life way easier.
So what are some of our
benefits and why it matters?
"Bird Box," if you all see
it, is a great movie, right?
Fantastic.
But being blind is terrible.
It's absolutely terrible.
And without proper
API management,
we were completely blind to
what was going on in the system.
We couldn't see what our
customers were seeing.
developers were experiencing.
So we were completely blind.
We needed that real-time
visibility into our production
API behavior, so that we
could respond proactively,
as opposed to waiting
for the telephone call
from an angry development
team saying, hey guys,
your stuff's broken.
Those calls are terrible
if you're an ops team.
We needed API management
to allow our teams
to view that real-time
usage, so that we
could make critical, proactive
decisions about scale.
When you're at 1,000
transactions a day,
that's a lot different
than 1,000 transactions
a second, right?
And the underlying
infrastructure
that's required to run that?
It matters.
So some of the challenges
that we experienced
before we put that
monitoring in place,
and before Apigee
introduced API monitoring?
Again, we were blind.
The clients would let us know.
I think the worst day was when
I had three or four development
teams--
two internal and one external--
send us emails telling us
that the APIs were 500.
OK, guys, we can't do this.
That's terrible.
We need to know exactly what's
going on inside our systems.
And then we were also guessing.
So we guessed a lot about
what the traffic patterns were
going to look like, what the
scale was going to look like.
We had tools that helped
us understand that.
But we didn't see
it in real time.
And API monitoring, when
they released it out
and my ops team kind of stumbled
upon it inside the management
suite, we're like
oh, man, goodness.
That is fantastic.
Let's get in on some of that.
And it became the space
where my team lived.
And so that's what I'm going
to take through right now.
Can we switch over to the demo?
We will take you
through our journey
and how we got to
where we're at.
So, first and foremost,
with the API management tool
that Apigee provides, they
give you a development portal,
which is great.
I didn't have to
create a website.
My team didn't have
to create a website.
We configured a website.
With productized the APIs
in Apigee Management Studio.
And then we exposed
them to developers.
It was fantastic.
And so what we got here
is basic API portal.
And I'm going to jump
right into our API docs.
And when we jump
into our API docs--
let's see if I can
click this guy.
There we go.
So here we have a set
of productized APIs
that are publicly available for
anyone to request access to.
Our model doesn't allow for just
ad hoc consumer integration.
So you have to become a
partner with Urban Science.
We'll then issue you a key.
But anybody can go
out and look at this.
If you actually want to
get into the real data,
you're going to have to
send an email, make a call,
we'll issue you a key.
It's all super secure.
But these are our basic
attribution products
that we have.
Again, these are a small subset
of publicly available APIs.
We have a large set of
privately available APIs
and a large set of
partner-available APIs
that we've exposed.
Again, all of this information
on the dev portal--
actually driven through
the API Management Studio,
based on the
productization of the work
that the ops team has done.
So we have all these
APIs that are out here,
that are available for someone
to integrate with and learn
more.
And you can drill down
into the Swagger docs
and learn all the contracts,
and all that stuff.
What I'm going to
take you through next
is our API Monitoring I'm going
to jump right into the API
Monitoring dashboard for our
Marketing Intelligence Cloud.
You can see we've got a
couple different proxies that
are running right now.
But this is where
my ops team lives.
So we've got all
of those APIs that
are out there, that are
public and productized.
What we've done is we've created
a set of collections that speak
to those attribution APIs.
So we've created
attribution apps.
And what we've done is--
not everything is as important
as everything, right?
So some of our API products are
far more important than others.
We have over 650, of which some
of them are very low consumer.
Some of them are administration.
Some of them are
customer-oriented.
So we've got a couple of
really big key API products
that are important to
us and to our customers.
And so we've
collectionized those.
We've created
collections out of them.
And we've made them a little
bit more watchful, if you will.
And so once we've got
our collection set up.
Then we've gone in and we've
made a series of alerts.
And you can see our alerts here.
We've got quite a bit of them.
We have a little saying at
Urban Science that we like.
It's basically, five over five.
So if you've got 5x errors over
five minutes and it repeats,
you're going to have a problem.
5x errors over five minutes
that doesn't repeat?
Latency issue, connectivity
issue, somebody's
having a couple of
hiccups or whatever?
Most of those, they
end up triaging
and they end up self-resolving,
and we don't really
worry about them.
But if we get five
over five repeatedly,
then we have a problem.
We need to go into what
Prithpal told you earlier-- more
that deep analysis
about root cause,
about why the error occurred,
and what's actually going on.
So we've got that collection
of APIs that we created.
And then we've turned those into
an alert for the attribution 5x
errors.
And then that allows us to
then subscribe to those alerts.
And my team, like I said, they
live inside this API monitoring
space.
Just like Prithpal
told you, we have
the alerts that come to the
email for proactive responses.
We have a lot of
different things
that this tooling has empowered
our team to be really visible
and see what's going on.
And it helped us
evolve from, hey,
we should do APIs, to
100 transactional APIs,
to over 10 million a month
with the same exact ops team.
So we've continued to
scale the infrastructure.
We've continued to
scale the system.
And with this tooling
in place, we've
been able to maintain that
small operational team
while also maintaining a high
customer satisfaction as well.
That pretty much wraps
up all of my demo,
I think we've got about 20
minutes or so for questions.
Prithpal, I'd like to
invite you to come back up
and we can take it from there.
PRITHPAL BHOGLI: Sure.
Thank you so much, Luke.
That was a great demo.
Thanks for taking
us through that.
And I think you had a couple
other dashboard out here.
But I think one of the--
I'm just going to start
summarizing it here in a few,
but I just want to go back
to the demo that he just did.
I think that was a great
example of how, in real life,
Urban Science is
using API monitoring
to stay ahead of what the
customers are experiencing.
And that was a very
powerful statement.
He said that we want to be
able to experience and see what
our customers are experiencing.
That's another example of
how API monitoring gives you
the tools to be able to be
proactive, determine what's
going on, and quickly
mitigate some of those issues.
Some of the alerting that
Lucas took us through,
graciously, was also a
mechanism to get alerted
on the channel of your choice.
So as an example, we
saw emails that I got.
But again, you can use
different notification channels
such as PagerDuty, Slack,
or pretty much anything
out there which had a webhook.
The picture that
you see out here,
again, is an extract
from their dashboard
out here, which gives you
the drill down capability
that we are talking about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]